it was certainly a lot of fun you know
we mentioned the raiders playing in
front of fans for the first time
it took them five games before they
finally heard a little cheering in the
stands kevin martin in kansas city
because some of those fans in the stands
were from raider nation
making their presence known for the
first time this season the raiders
played in front of
live spectators as the kansas city
chiefs were one of six
teams in these week five matchups to
allow fans
inside their stadium and boy did the
fans for the raiders have a lot to cheer
for
as tonight the raiders ended their seven
year winless drought here
at arrowhead stadium
[Music]
it's been one one heck of experience
being able to see him in person the
silver and black came out
did what they had to do on the field
give kansas city that first loss
i'm i'm proud to be repping the raider
nation
in kansas city in animator in enemy
territory
we're happy we won we're happy to
represent the raiders in their first
game
that fans have been able to support them
and we're with them
win loser draw we're there so excited
that they won so happy that they won
it was a great game a high scoring game
and yeah so much fun now we're happy to
celebrate
and man what a way for this fan base to
head into the bye week
on a high note 1-0 in the afc west and
on the horizon another huge test tom
brady and the buccaneers come to town
on october 25th reporting outside of
arrowhead stadium kevin martin 8 sports
now